bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette foire aux questions sur un
tract aux sciences fois en question pour
laquelle j'ai l'honneur d'accueillir
pour la deuxième fois sur cette chaîne
le docteur lucas legendre lucas bonjour
bonjour donc lucas a tué paléontologue à
l'université d'austin texas et tu viens
de publier un magnifique article dans la
revue les nageurs sur antarctique en
partie au lit tu embarques tollitte us 7
serait le tu va m'apprendre à le
prononcer qui serait donc le premier
ruff de possiblement mozart découvert au
monde donc déjà est-ce qu'on peut
commencer
comment ça se dit alors en partie colite
us c'est un peu long mon parti politique
donc le loeuff de l'antarctique
tout à fait le fossile de l'antarctique
et donc
donc c'est vraiment enfin je vais je
vais montrer des images là l'écran pour
montrer la pièce ce que c'est en fait
est ce que tu peux un peu nous raconter
l'histoire de toi ce qui t'a amené à
étudier ce ça parce que honnêtement
enfin enfin on va en parler mais au
départ quand j'ai vu ça quand tu l'a
montré pour la première fois on s'était
vus en congrès tu m'avais montrer ça en
fait il nous avait présenté sa en
congrès et c'était en face à ressembler
une grosse crotte de nez du coup est ce
que tu peux nous raconter l'histoire de
comment tu t'es retrouvé à étudier
quelque chose comme ça hu est arrivé un
peu par hasard en fait c'est parce que
moi la passe je travaille pas du tout
sur les oeufs c'est pas ma spécialité ni
celle de tous les gens qui ont travaillé
avec moi sur cette étude donc ça s'est
fait de manière un peu fort suit en fait
l'oeuf lui-même il a été découvert en
2011 par une équipe de paléontologues
chiliens qui étaient dans le cas d'une
expédition antarctique financé par le
gouvernement chilien pour trouver entre
autres défauts side
je cherchais majoritairement des
fossiles de reptiles marins ils en ont
trouvé pas mal d'ailleurs
et un jour en prospectant ils sont
tombés sur ces espèces de drôles de
trucs un peu fous il savait pas trop ce
que c'était ils ont quand même préparé
et rapportés avec eux au musée
de santiago au cas où mais ils n'ont pas
vraiment travailler dessus parce qu'il
pensait pas que ça va être un fossile de
particulièrement intéressant donc il est
resté dans un tiroir pendant les années
qui ont suivi
et en fait ce qui a démarré l'étude de
ce spécimen c'est quand maman 42
post-doc donc d'oublier clark qui est
directrice du labo où je suis
actuellement à austin est allé dans les
collections du muséum de santiago pour
travailler sur un projet qui n'a aucun
rapport mais est tombé dessus un peu par
hasard en prospectant dans les
collections s'est tout de suite dit que
ça pouvait potentiellement être un gros
oeuf fossile et obtenu l'autorisation de
récupérer quelques fragments de la
coquille pour les rapporter à austin
pour qu'on puisse les étudier et moi à
ce moment-là j'ai je commençais mon post
doc dans ce labo là aussi sur un projet
qui n'a rien à voir avec les ou mais du
coup comme je suis à la base plutôt dans
tout ce qui est microscopie histologie
et statistiques comparatives giulia
madiba récupère les fragments fait
quelques coupes
amuse-toi faire quelques analyses
préliminaires pour voir ce que ça
pourrait être est ce que ça pourrait
être un neuf ou pas et sans plus de
détails on n'est vraiment pas trouvé
grand-chose pensais qu'on avait trouvé
que ça va être une grosse concrétions et
qu'on m'avait abandonné tout de suite et
puis bah plus en plus on obtenait de
résultats plomb ce rendez compte que
c'était bon plus intéressant que ce
qu'on croyait à la base et du coup ça a
donné cette espèce d'études avec
beaucoup plus de collaborateurs et de
méthode et de dana l'isq que ce qu'on
espérait à l'origine ouais ouais c'est
quand même c'est quand même un beau
résultat inattendu quand une publication
dans knight cher non c'est intéressant
c'est du coup c'est vraiment juste de la
pure curiosité quoi c'est à dire que
celle où ils ont trouvé un truc qui
ressemble et qui était bizarre en
antarctique
il aurait pu ne pas le ramener mais ils
ont choisi de le ramener et puis après
tu attends ta superviseurs qui d'un seul
coup se dit tiens c'est marrant ça et si
on y regarde et est donc tu as regardé
ça complètement ses essais à côté en
fait de ce que tu étais censé faire tu
avais une mission on va dire pour ton
post doc et s'était complètement à côté
quoi la mairie match et j'ai toujours
d'ailleurs ça reste un sujet principal
de pollock et ça c'est à la base c'était
un projet complètement un exquis seul
qui a plu
en plus d'importance parce qu'on
prouvait le plus en plus de trucs mais
ouais c'est ça s'est vraiment fait est
ce que par hasard ouais c'est super cool
comme l'histoire donc justement
puisqu'on en parle comment comment on
sait que c'est pas juste un os du loup
une concrétion parce que c'est vrai que
il ya beaucoup de gens qui et quand on
n'est pas des entomologues alors
maintenant que toi tu vas être étiqueté
spécial spécialiste des oeufs
tu vas certainement recevoir plein
d'e-mails comme ça de gens qui tendrait
des photos de cailloux rond et puis un
kit demande si c'est un oeuf de
dinosaure
donc comment on sait que quelque chose
n'est ou n'est pas un oeuf de dinosaure
ou d'autres choses c'est vrai que oui
c'est très très commun d'avoir un des
gens qui voient qu'ils trouvent des
grosses pierres encore on y pense tout
de suite que la presse que c'est un oeuf
fossile de dinosaure autre chose il ya
eu il ya eu pas mal d'études sur les os
fossiles qui ont été faites au cours des
dernières décennies c'est quand même un
sujet qui a été très étudié les
caractères principaux qu'on utilise pour
étudier ça ça va être la structure de la
coquille donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
prélève des fragments alors généralement
même en regardant le fossile dans son
ensemble lui même on peut déjà avoir un
premier indice si on a une structure qui
ressemble un peu pas forcément une
coquille mais qui est très différente du
sédiment
là c'était le cas on a vraiment une
espèce de couches très fines sur tout le
pourtour de l'oeuf qui a vraiment une
couleur et une texture qui sont
complètement différentes de celles du
sédiment autour c'est bien visible sur
les sur certaines des photos et c'est
visible aussi sur les coupes fines qu'on
a fait on pourrait vraiment bien la
coquille qui distingue du sédiment et
après bah on compare par rapport aux
autres fossiles qui ont été trouvés qui
ont été publiées dans la littérature
donc ça c'est le en fait on a regardé
dès le départ on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait pas alors juste pour faire
une petite précision qui peut
probablement être importante par la
suite tous les oeufs de reptiles ont une
la coquille à une structure en deux
parties en gros la partie extérieure et
très minéralisée très dense si on pense
par exemple à un oeuf de poule deltell
qu'on en mange c'est la partie qu'on
voit à l'extérieur quand on casse la
coquille et à l'intérieur vous avez une
autre membrane une membrane beaucoup
plus fine qui elle est et protéique
donc il est complètement molle et alors
chez les oeufs d'oiseaux chez les e2
crocodile chez les tortues la membrane
est très fine et la partie minéralisée
est très épaisse et chez les e2
notamment lézards et serpents celle
inverse la partie minéralisée très fine
et la membrane est très épaisse et là
notre gros oeuf fossile
on a tout de suite vu que la partie
minéralisée était super signes qui avait
pas ces structures minéralisées très
dense qu'on a chez les oiseaux par
exemple est par contre la membrane est
très épaisse et à cette structure très
très stratifié convoi très fréquemment
chez les e2 squamates donc on s'est tout
de suite dit a potentiellement c-19 à
coke immolé non pas qu qui dure
auquel cas ce serait de la préservation
exceptionnelles puisque c'est très très
rare évidemment puisque c'est protéique
de retrouver dans le registre fossile et
on s'est tout de suite dit que ça devait
être un spécimen donc plus
exceptionnelle que prévu initialement
d'ailleurs ça fait écho à une découverte
qui a été publié en même temps que la
tienne ce que les dinosaures avaient
possiblement aussi des des coquilles
molle à la base en fait ils avaient
éventuellement cette même structure de
coquilles potentiellement oui bah
l'homme là aussi c'est une super
découvert ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont ils
ont publié les yeux de deux espèces de
petits dinosaures un sauropodomorphes et
un ceyrat obtient tous les deux avaient
clairement une structure oui un peu
assez similaire avec donc la partie
minéralisée très fine la partie
protéines très épaisse et du coup alors
est ce que ça veut dire que tous les
dinosaures et ancestralement comme ça
le propose nous on a trouvé un résultat
inverse avec des données un peu
différent ça dépend dans quel bac sont
inclus dans l'analyse mais
potentiellement oui il y avait beaucoup
plus de dinosaures avec des locaux qui
molle que ce qu'on pensait avant ouais
d'accord donc et du coup est-ce que vous
avez regardé à l'intérieur s'il ya un
embryon
oui c'est un des premiers trucs qu'on a
fait le david mon co auteur qui est à
découvrir l'oeuvre sur le terrain a fait
un site is khan il m'a envoyé les
données donc on a vraiment garder et
malheureusement on n'a rien trouvé et
que alors il est rempli sédiments il est
vraiment ça préserver toute la structure
tridimensionnelle de l'oeuf et comme il
ya aussi une grosse couverture sur le
côté on soupçonne qu en fait cédé 1,9
qui avait déjà éclos et que du coup
c'est pour ça qu'il s'est remplie de
sédiments il a dû déposer comme ça sur
le fond et ça probablement d'ailleurs
aidé à sa préservation puisqu'on avait
des sédiments à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur
d'accord et du coup ça pose la question
de la fin déjà ça pose la question de
l'identification de cette espèce qui est
probablement un reptile marin mais du
coup ça pose aussi la question de 2 est
ce que ces reptiles marins étaient
ovipare ou vivipare quoi tout à fait mal
à ça a été aussi le truc qui nous a
beaucoup surpris c'est que alors
évidemment quand on a commencé à faire
les analyses statistiques pour comparer
s'étoffe avec les autres eux qui ont été
décrits dans la littérature
on a tout de suite regardé du côté des
squames ait forcément puisque c'est ce
qui ressemble le plus gégé a semblé
comme ça un assez gros je tenais avec
thé et caractère prix du taux surplus en
espèces de squales maths et puis
d'autres reptiles aussi après allez ça
va passer êtes tu peux tu peux nous dire
ce que sont des squamates s'il te plaît
ah oui alors les squames accès lézards
serpents et quelques autres groupes et
donc on est on sait tout de suite rendu
compte que cet oeuf le une des
principales particularités qu'il a c'est
que déjà les normes certes et c'est déjà
très surprenant mais aussi la coquille
est incroyablement fine par rapport à sa
taille il fait dans les selfs 100
micromètres d'épaisseur ce qui est trois
fois plus fin que ce à quoi on aurait pu
s'attendre pour 1,9 à coki molle de
cette taille-là donc tout de suite on
s'est dit c'est très bizarre pourquoi
c'est si fin
a priori c'est pas du tout avantageux
d'avoir une coquille aussi fine pour 1,9
aussi gros comment la structure était
fiable sur le long terme et du coup en
regardant chez les squamates en fait les
squamates et beaucoup d'espèces qui sont
dits par le lait les arts et les
serpents il ya plus d'une centaine
l'apparition indépendant indépendante de
la vie parité chez les lézards et
serpents ce qui est unique dans le les
reptiles et en fait ce qu'on appelle les
disparités pour les arts et les serpents
c'est en fait techniquement quand même
un neuf
c'est à dire que on a un oeuf qui est
qui dans lequel embryons se développent
mais qui va avoir une coquille tellement
fine que les échanges gazeux et de
nutriments sont directement à travers la
coupe si il n'y a pas forcément besoin
de port puisque la partie minéralisée
est quasi absente
et quand l'oeuf et expulsé du ventre de
la mère il est clos généralement
instantanément quelques minutes après
avoir été pondu ce qui fait que du coup
là c'est pour ça qu'on parle du dih
parité parce que du coup les petits sont
complètement formés et sort du ventre de
la mère instantanément au moment de la
ponte à des clauses ion mais la pompe
donc à peu près en même temps mais
techniquement talk en baisse à 1,9 c'est
ça qu'on appelle lé ovovivipare était
alors oui le truc c'est alors le terme
est tombé en peu en désuétude au fil du
temps parce qu'en fait c'est un
continuel c'est-à-dire xvi paraît
ovipare il ya plein d'état un peu
intermédiaire ça dépend de combien de
temps embryon est dans le ventre de la
mère
ça dépend de quel point le bébé est
développée au moment de sortir de l'oeuf
et plusieurs paramètres
donc du coup pour éviter d'avoir des
confusions de mettre dans le même sac et
des trucs qui vont pas forcément
ensemble les chercheurs qui travaillent
là-dessus utilise plus trop le terme de
bobigny parité mais c'est un peu ça oui
certains 9 qui tout de suite après avoir
été pondus tous les rats serpents visi
part actuelle on d une coquille d'oeuf a
du coup c'est ce n'est plus ça n'est
plus qu'une membrane qui est beaucoup
beaucoup plus fine et quasiment pas
minéralisée que celle de leurs
confrère proche ovipare et du coup on a
comme ça plein de groupes de lézards et
serpents qui ont acquis ce type de
morphologie de la coquille et du coup vu
que notre gros oeuf mystère les très
gros mais il a une copie très fine
on s'est tout de suite dit que peut-être
ça correspondait à sa banque 1,9 l
animal qui est visé par et qui éclot
instantanément au moment de la ponte
ce qui expliquerait pourquoi il était
désespérément tout seul qui ait pas
vraiment de deux fossiles autour de lui
il y avait il y avait quoi comme type de
fossiles retrouvés autour de cet oeuf
alors en proximité directe il n'y a pas
vraiment grand chose le plus proche il
c'est un fossile de mozart qui était
trouvée est publié à quelques années
qu'ils pouvaient à peu près 200 m dos
l'oeuvre donc c'est pas vraiment
proximité directe mais c'est le en tout
cas la taille correspondrait parce que
c'est un oiseau géant qui devait se
mesurer dans les dix ou douze mètres et
puis un truc qui est assez rigolo aussi
c'est que à l'intérieur de l'oeil on a
une petite ammonites qui a été préservé
ce qui du coup nous orienterait aussi
sur l'idée que l'homme avait déjà éclos
et du coup la manita aurait peut-être pu
rentrer dans l'oeuf à la recherche de
nutriments pour se nourrir d des restes
du liquide amniotique ou autres et s'est
retrouvé piégé dans l'offre est
probablement été préservés comme ça
d'accord et ouais du coup le fait de
retrouver des démos à tort contemporain
ça soutient l'idée que ce sera un mozart
il ya quoi d'autre comme argument qui
qui permettent de discuter de
l'attribution de cet oeuf bas alors déjà
je précise les mosasaures sont
techniquement des lézards donc c'est ça
serait pas du tout surprenant vu qu'ils
ont acheté stratégie qui a paru plein de
fois chez les arts et les serpents de la
retrouver aussi chez les mots à tort et
puis sinon bah le truc c'est en fait on
a procédé un peu par élimination on a
regardé tous les animaux qui nous dit
retrouver dans cette formation de
géologie comme en antarctique pour voir
ce qu'ils vivaient là et est ce que les
autres animaux qui vivaient là aurait pu
pondre cette heure est à la base il y
avait plusieurs candidats potentiels
alors évidemment on a tout de suite
pensé aux ptérosaures parce que les
ptérosaures pondent des oeufs le coq
imola certains d'entre eux en tout cas
mais les ptérosaures qu'on en trouve en
antarctique était beaucoup trop petit
pour avoir pondu un oeuf de cette taille
là donc ça les éliminer d'entrée
et puis alors on a regardé les
dinosaures nouri viewer nous ont demandé
tout de suite à mais est ce que ça
pourrait pas être un oeuf de dinosaure
et alors ça pourrait en théorie surtout
avec cette nouvelle découverte d ea
comme si molle de dinosaures qui
viennent d'être publiées au 6 mai notre
fils a une particularité aussi c'est
qu'il est très allongée en forme la
forme générale de l'oeuf et très
allongée or les seuls gros dinosaures
qui était assez gros en antarctique pour
contre 7,9 c'était des sauropodes
or tous les sauropodes sans exception le
pont deh e éric donc la forme ne
correspond pas et sinon les autres
dinosaures antarctique ont là des
théropodes rose or no tamment était trop
petit pour avoir pondu un oeuf de cette
taille-là vu de tes modèles qu'on a fait
avec nos autres autres reptiles pour nos
modèles statistiques
donc du coup les candidats les plus
probables peut-être qu'à quelques pas
rapt et rose or ou un dinosaure géant
qui attendent d'être découverte en
antarctique ont pondu cet oeuf
mais en attendant il peut-être la plus
probable ça reste un reptile marin donc
un mot adore on peut être un plésiosaure
d'accord
bon je vais poser la question pour les
gens qui connaissent le moins bien la
paléontologie mais pourquoi pas un
ichtyosaure alors les ichtyosaures déjà
y en a pas d'article on n'a jamais
retrouvé
et puis en plus de ça ils ont disparu
vers le milieu du crétacé donc bien
avant le crétacé supérieur qui est
l'époque halde dont dont est issu ce
spécimen mis en jeu c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas dit je précise ce gros oeuf qui
vient du crétacé supérieur il ya environ
68 millions d'années on est vraiment à
la toute fin du crétacé d'accord donc et
puis il ya aussi le fait qu'on peut
taton est ce que c est ce que c'est très
bien établie salt lake city aux orres
donné naissance à des petits directement
vivant ou est ce que est ce que du coup
on t'a découverte ne remettrait pas en
question sa skis éventuellement on
n'aurait pas en fait des ichtyosaures
qui donnait naissance à des oeufs qui
éclosent très vite après après avoir été
pendus bah ça c'est très difficile à
dire répond c'est où qu'on peut toujours
tout remettre en question
c'est vrai que le a priori vu que cette
cette membrane c'est cet oeuf festiciel
qui n'est plus qu'une membrane non
minéralisée techniquement de l'ap temps
la plupart des cas ne va pas se
préserver
donc on peut toujours supposer que oui
la plupart des reptiles marins avec des
structures comme ça qui se préservent
repas chez des fossiles et chaque fois
qu'on trouve un foetus à l'intérieur du
temps d'un adulte on peut toujours
supposer qu'il y avait une membrane
présente à l'origine après évidemment on
n'aura jamais la certitude donc toujours
difficile d'en discuter
d'accord et alors
j'ai une dernière question c'est la
question de la ponte des oeufs sur terre
ou dans l'eau ah oui alors ça ça a été
un long sujet le débat avec tous les
membres de mon labo ma chef du bien
a directement pensé mais peut-être qu'il
pouvait lui va mettre une partie de leur
corps sur terre sans sortir de l'eau et
chaque fois je le disais mais quand même
ça pas grand sens pourquoi est ce qu' il
ferait autant d'efforts pour pondre sur
terre pour que les petits reviennent à
l'eau immédiatement après sachant que
l'or effectivement c'est ce qu'on a chez
les tortues mais les tortues peuvent
sortir de l'eau les tortues marines
peuvent sortir de l'eau pour vraiment
enterrer leur zoo dans le sable
là on sait de par la morphologie de
leurs membres de par leur taille que les
grands mots açores et plésiosaures était
beaucoup trop gros et y avait des
membres pas du tout adapté pour déplacer
sur la terre ferme
ils seraient ils ont été écrasés sous
leur propre poids ça aurait pas été
possible
donc du coup oui on peut toujours
considérer l'hypothèse mais ça semble
quand même très improbable qu'il ait
réussi à sortir de l'eau à se hisser sur
la sur la plage par exemple sur la terre
ferme pour les rouleurs the sur terre ça
semble quand même très improbable
d'accord et le paléo environnement dans
lequel vous avez trouvé cette fille il
indique quoi plutôt bas alors ça aussi
ça a été un argument en faveur des
reptiles marins c'est à dire que le tout
la formation en fait c'est donc une
formation marine en eaux peu profondes
et de par la géologie les gens qui ont
travaillé là dessus notamment des chiens
notamment mais que auteurs ont identifié
que c'était probablement un
environnement un peu comme une lagune un
peu comme une pelle et à un
environnement assez protégé avec thé
avec d autres profonde et depuis une
vingtaine d'années on a retrouvé
énormément de squelettes de reptiles
marins dans cette zone là évidemment des
mozart et des plésiosaures tous de très
grande taille pour les adultes et on a
retrouvé énormément de juvéniles ce qui
normalement est rare pour les reptiles
marins
donc du coup plusieurs auteurs ont
supposé que m'a peut-être c'était une
mer un peu comme une nursery un endroit
où les élèves qui ne parvenait pour pour
pondre enfin pour donner naissance à
leurs petits
maintenant du coup aussi peut être
potentiellement que quiconque a des yeux
plutôt que de simplement donner
naissance à des petits sans rien auto
mais du coup il probablement les parents
pour y secourir en non plus
plus profonde puisque c'étaient des
prédateurs pélagiques de grandes eaux
mais venez pour se reproduire en eaux
moins profondes dans une zone plus
protégés et c'est pour ça qu'on a
retrouvé autant de petits d'accord bah
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accordé de
ton temps pour cette interview
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
dans la fin que tu tenais à dire mais
que je ne t'ai pas permis de d'exprimer
bas merci pour m'avoir proposé de la
faire et puis bah non c'est un projet
vraiment super on a travaillé c'était
vraiment bien d'avoir à la fois des
américains des chiens et puis moi de me
retrouver au milieu de ça complètement
par hasard
donc ça va vraiment être un beau projet
ouais j'ai appris tellement de trucs sur
les oeufs sur la microscopie et sur une
méthode que le j'espère pouvoir
continuer à travailler sur le sujet
prochainement
ok tu gardes ton cas c'est une super
histoire c'est une super histoire c'est
une super découverte et j'espère que tu
en feras encore plein d'autres comme ça
et comme ça on pourra très invité pour
une autre interview oui voila voila
merci
bon bah merci beaucoup de nous avoir
accordé de ton temps je te souhaite
beaucoup de courage pour tes futurs
interview parce que je sais que tu vas
en avoir plein d'autres à une prochaine
fois et à tous à tous nos auditeurs
jeudi à la prochaine sur notre chaîne
[Musique]